>> Eric Hoplin: I'd
like to welcome everyone
to this exciting session, this
author's series here today
with Stuart Eizenstat.
My name is Eric Hoplin.
I'm the head of the External
Relations at Wells Fargo.
And I'm really honored
to be here today in part
because I brought
my three young boys.
They're so excited
for this session.
They're so excited to meet
authors and to celebrate reading
and to celebrate literacy.
You know, at Wells Fargo,
we find, we think literacy
and education and
reading is so important.
In fact, they're the building
blocks of a successful
and an enriching life.
And that's why we're proud,
once again, for the eighth year
in a row, to be the
charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
In fact, we focus on reading
all throughout the year.
Last year, Wells Fargo, we
gave out more than 57,000 books
and our team members read
to 104,000 children
all around the country.
Now, I have to tell you, if
you're looking for fun things
to do at the National
Book Festival today,
after this session,
I would suggest
to go all the way
downstairs to the basement
to the America Reads
Pavilion and there,
there are Wells Fargo
volunteers that are going
to host great activities
for the entire family.
In fact, my boys and I, we just
did a horse bouncy racing game.
They beat me.
They're a little younger than I
am, a little faster than I am.
It's so much fun but
we've got great authors
that are reading to children.
We have an audio book section,
arts and crafts,
and so much more.
So come on down to
that pavilion.
But without further
ado, I'm very excited
to introduce this panel.
Wells Fargo is so excited to
be a part of this program.
And of course, I want to turn it
over to our moderator
this morning.
He's the Co-chairman of
the National Book Festival
and of course, we all know the
incomparable David Rubinstein.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Thank
you very much [applause].
So thank you very much.
So how many people, how
many people here lived
through the Washington
DC in the Carter years?
How many people were
living in Washington?
Okay. How many people worked
in the Carter administration?
Okay. How many people
have met Jimmy Carter?
Okay. Well, we have a
terrific person to talk
about the Carter administration,
the Carter White House,
and Jimmy Carter
and my former boss.
I was one of his deputies
at the White House
with Stuart Eizenstat.
Let me give Stuart an
introduction before we talk
about his book which
has come out now.
It's President Carter,
the White House Years .
And I highly recommend
it to people.
Let me talk about
Stuart's background.
Stuart is a native of Atlanta,
went to Grady High School
where he was an All-American
basketball player.
Yes, that's true,
All-American basketball player.
He then went to University
of North Carolina
where he did not play
basketball but he tried
out in the freshman year
and concluded he'd be better
as an academic performer.
And he graduated Phi Beta Kappa.
He then went to Harvard
Law School and from there,
he later came into the Johnson
White House and worked there
for President Johnson.
And then in 1968, campaigned
for Hubert Humphrey.
He then went back to
Atlanta, practiced law there.
Became a partner in a firm
called Hall Goldstein.
And then he got to know somebody
who was running for governor
of Georgia named Jimmy Carter.
He got involved in helping
him in that election campaign
and then later, he got involved
with helping Jimmy Carter
in his 1976 campaign for
president of the United States.
And he was his principal
policy adviser.
And then he was the principal
domestic policy adviser during
the four years at
the White House.
Since that time, Stuart has
served in government as well,
in the Clinton administration,
serving as initially
our Ambassador
to the European Union, later as
the Undersecretary of Commerce
for International Trade.
Later then, as the
Undersecretary
of Economic Affairs at the
State Department and then later,
as Deputy Secretary of Treasury.
During the Obama administration,
he served in an ex-officio role
as a person who helped deal with
a Holocaust asset collection
and has done incredible work
in making certain that people
who had assets taken away
from them during the Holocaust
have them given back to them,
to the rightful owners.
Stuart is the father of two
sons and the grandfather
of eight grandchildren.
Is that right?
And he has written
several other books
but let's focus today
on this one.
So Stuart, thank you
very much for coming.
The Carter administration
ended roughly 40 years ago.
So why did you wait almost
40 years to write this book
about President Carter and how
did you have the time to do it?
You have a job as a
partner in a law firm.
You've been practicing law for
a number of years in Washington
as well in Covington
and Burling.
How did you have time to do
this and was it a labor of love
or was it difficult
going back through some
of the difficult times
of the Carter years?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
It was a labor of love.
As you remember very well
and painfully, in 1980,
President Carter suffered
the greatest political defeat
of any incumbent
president in modern times.
And since then and up until
the time of the publication
of this book, that
meant for many people
that he had a failed presidency.
And I decided it was time
to write a reassessment
of the Carter presidency,
warts and all.
It's honest and candid about the
mistakes but it also recognizes,
in my opinion, that he
was the most accomplished
and under-appreciated one-term
president in American history.
Seventy percent of our
legislation passed.
[ Applause ]
And Walter Mondale,
his vice-president,
put it very succinctly.
We told the truth.
We obeyed the law and
we kept the peace.
But there's so much more
than that, okay [applause].
>> David M. Rubinstein: Well,
let me ask you about this.
By the way, was this
an authorized book
that Jimmy Carter
asked you to do this?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
It is absolutely not
an authorized book.
I've conducted 350
interviews, five times with him
from 1991 through 2013.
I interviewed people who
were positive and negative,
who were detractors
and supporters.
And I have and I think
the authenticity, David,
of the book depends not only on
these interviews but the fact
that I kept over 5000 pages
of contemporaneous notes
on 103 legal pads
of verbatim notes
of everything I saw and I heard.
And I called it as
it was and I told him
when I started writing
this book,
I was going to do
it warts and all.
And if I didn't do that,
then the positive aspects
would be discounted
and I think he understood this.
He maybe shirks a little
bit at some of the warts
but I think he overall has been
very supportive of the book
and recognizes that it does
give a new reassessment
of the Carter presidency.
And interestingly, David, his
political hero was Harry Truman.
And he took his famous
slogan, "The buck stops here,"
and put it on his
Oval Office desk.
Both left the White
House highly unpopular.
Truman is now remembered
more for his achievements
than his failures and I hope my
book will have a similar impact
on Carter as president, not just
as an admired former president.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Usually, people who work
in White House staffs, they
write one of two types of books.
They are, "I'm great but
the president wasn't great,"
or [laughter] "I'm great and
the president was great."
But you wrote one that
says, "I'm just pretty good
but not perfect," and
about Carter, you said,
"He was pretty good
but not perfect."
So when you had to
relive your mistakes
and relive his mistakes,
was that painful?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: It
was painful but I wanted it
to be an honest book and
I did not decide the name
of this book, if they had only
listened to me [laughter].
Now I could have said because
David was my immediate deputy
before he was the
David Rubinstein.
And I could have said that
all of the successes were due
to your recommendations.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right.
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So
the failures, to mine.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Hardly the case.
>> Stuart Eizenstat: But I've
decided not to do that as well.
You know, I mean, it is a book
which is honest about
my mistakes.
I didn't, for example, catch
inflation early enough.
I didn't give him
the right advice
when Burt Lance was declining.
There were a number of things
that I made mistakes on as well
and I think, again, that
gives it a credibility.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Okay, so let's go back
to when you first
met Jimmy Carter.
When did you first meet him?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: This is a
good story about how in politics
and perhaps, in life as well,
one should follow one's
heart and not mind.
So after a year in the
Johnson White House
and then a half-a-year as Hubert
Humphrey's Research Director
in the '68 campaign
against Nixon, when he lost,
I went back to Atlanta,
my hometown.
Clerked for a federal
judge and made a beeline
for the sumptuously
well-appointed office
of former Governor Carl Sanders
who was going to run again.
He was odds-on favorite.
I said, "I'm a hometown boy.
I worked in the White House
for Johnson and Humphrey.
I'd like to help you."
He didn't need my help.
He gave me a very brief meeting
and a high school friend said,
"You ought to meet a former
State Senator, Jimmy Carter,
who has run unsuccessfully once
in 1960 and is running again.
And I said, "No, I've made
a commitment to Carter.
Well, he badgered me so much.
I finally did.
And the meeting could not
have been a greater contrast
with Carl Sanders
who was well-coifed
in a well-upholstered office.
But Jimmy Carter, I met
him in a very stark office
that had one table, two
metal folding chairs.
He was dressed in khaki pants
and an open shirt
and work boots.
But what attracted me, David,
and it was an attraction
that has remained to
this day, is first,
he was highly intelligent.
But second, I saw him
as someone who had come
from a gnat-infested hamlet of
500 people in Southwest Georgia
but understood the urban
problems of Atlanta.
He favored mass transit.
He favored education.
And most important for me,
he favored civil rights.
He said, "The time for
discrimination is over."
And that sold me on him.
And he took that into
his governorship.
That was, in fact,
the key ingredient
of his inaugural
address as governor.
He put Martin Luther King's
portrait in the State Capitol
which I can assure you,
was highly unpopular.
And civil rights
became an enduring part
of his presidential
legacy as well.
And so then, and again, as a
sort of humorous moment, in '74,
he was appointed by Bob
Strauss, the Chairman
of the Democratic
National Committee
to head the Congressional
Campaign Committee
for the '74 election and
he asked me to present,
produce a series
of issue papers.
We did about 25 or 30 on every
issue critiquing the Nixon
administration and
giving alternatives
that Democratic candidates
could run on.
When we finished that, I
called him up and I said,
"I'd like to take you
out to lunch, Governor.
I've got an idea."
We sat at this restaurant in
Underground Atlanta and I said,
"Look, I've got sort
of wild hare.
If you run for president,
there's going to be a need
for a Southern on the ticket.
If you win a few
Southern primaries
and knock George Wallace out,
perhaps you'll get
the second post."
And he said, in his toothy
grin, "I'm going to run
and I don't intend
to be vice-president.
Would you like to join my
presidential campaign?"
[Laughter] So from '74 on,
I became his policy director
and the rest is history.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
How did you, how did you --
you were practicing law
and how did you have time
to practice law and also
help him in the campaign?
What did you tell
your law partner?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: The same
way, David, that people say,
"How can you be on
20 nonprofit boards?
How can you run a
major corporation?"
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Right [laughter].
>> Stuart Eizenstat: And that
is the good Lord put 24 hours
in a day.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
All right, so you did that.
Now, Carter's strategy
was fairly unique.
It was to focus on Iowa.
Many people hadn't realized
that Iowa was so important.
What was his strategy
on Iowa and actually,
did he win Iowa or not?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So why
did Carter win the nomination
against well-financed,
well-known congressmen
and senators like Udall and Bayh
and so many others,
Scoop Jackson?
It was for two or three reasons.
First of all, he was an
indefatigable campaigner.
He campaigned before the Iowa
caucuses for a hundred days
and before anyone knew that the
Iowa caucuses meant anything.
They were, after all, only
caucuses, not a primary.
He understood that under
the new McGovern rules
which had just come into effect,
that the party bosses
would no longer be able
in smoke-filled rooms
to choose a nominee.
The people were going to get it.
And so he went to homes.
He carried his own bags
and he went, again,
in a hundred different
instances and Rosalynn as well.
But there's a second
reason he won.
And that is, he, alone among
the Democratic candidates,
recognized that what the
American people wanted
in the presidential election
of '76 was not a revival
of LBJ's Great Society.
And having worked for Johnson,
it's something I
would have liked.
No, that's not what
people wanted.
In a post-Watergate era,
they wanted honesty,
integrity, transparency.
And when he promised,
"I'll never tell a lie.
A government is as
good as its people."
That's what struck at the
cords of people's hearts.
And did he win Iowa?
This is, again, an
interesting story.
He got 27% of the vote in Iowa.
Birch Bayh got 13%.
Undecided got 60% [laughter].
Headlines, "Carter Wins
Iowa" and that vaunted us
on to New Hampshire and
into the White House.
>> David M. Rubinstein: And
as I remember, I recall,
I think that the amount
of votes he got to get
that percentage was about
11,000 or something like that.
Today, it takes about
100,000 to win Iowa.
So it's much smaller.
So he goes to New Hampshire
and all of a sudden,
he wins New Hampshire.
Is that right?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
He wins New Hampshire
and New Hampshire allows
itself the same kind
of retail politicking that you
can do in Iowa, house-to-house,
small town meetings,
town hall meetings.
They want to know
that you're there.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right.
>> Stuart Eizenstat: And so
again, he used that same thing.
Government is as
good as its people.
Ethics reform, moral
high ground.
But then, he began
to broaden it.
After all, he was running
at a Democratic primary.
He talked about the
need for education.
need for investment.
>> David M. Rubinstein: And
what was the Peanut Brigade?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So after
we won in and I put quote,
unquote -- "won" in Iowa,
a so-called Peanut
Brigade was started
by a woman named Dot Padgett.
He had been, of course,
a peanut farmer,
and they got together
hundreds of people from Georgia
who went door-to-door
in New Hampshire,
literally door-to-door,
handing out his literature.
And this Peanut Brigade
plus his whole family
and Rosalynn being an
incredible campaigner.
And this was an interesting
story in and of itself.
When he ran for governor,
Rosalynn was so shy,
she literally shook
on the podium.
She could hardly speak.
She evolved into a
tremendous campaigner.
And by the way, a
great First Lady.
Only the second First Lady after
Eleanor Roosevelt to testify
in Congress and this on her own
legislation of mental health.
So she was an enormous asset.
The Peanut Brigade
really spread the word
and got him door-to-door
in New Hampshire.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Are you
amazed at after all these years,
people still call her
Rosalynn, Rosalynn?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
It's Rosalynn.
It's Rosalynn but it's Rosalynn.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Okay,
so he wins New Hampshire.
He's moving forward
to get the nomination.
All of a sudden, the liberals in
the party say, "Wait a second.
This moderate or conservative
could be the nominee
of the party."
Did they try to come together
and get one candidate?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So the rest
of the crowd made a
fundamental mistake.
They said, "Let's let
Carter do the dirty work
of getting George Wallace,
the segregationist governor
of Alabama, out of the race.
We'll give him a clear field in
North Carolina and in Florida.
Then we'll take him on."
By then, it was too late.
When we won North Carolina
and we won Florida,
we developed a momentum
that was almost unstoppable
but there were two
huge road bumps
on the way to the nomination.
The first was that going into
the first northern primary
in Pennsylvania, we had
to broaden the message.
He was not just a
Southern candidate.
And he incorrectly thought
the way to do it was appeal
to perhaps the worst instincts
of the white working class.
And so he used the term,
"preserving the ethnic purity
of ethnic neighborhoods" --
Polish, Czech and so forth.
That caused an uproar.
Here was a virtually unknown
candidate and even the mayor
of Atlanta, Maynard
Jackson, said,
"This is not the
Jimmy Carter I know.
Maybe we got the wrong guy."
He was saved by one
absolutely crucial thing.
Andrew Young had been the
first congressman elected
from the Deep South
since reconstruction.
And I have helped him and my
late wife, Fran, had helped him.
I called Andy up and I said,
"Andy, you know Carter.
You know that he's
not a racist."
Andy got Daddy King, that's
Martin Luther King Senior --
Junior had already
been assassinated --
head of the Ebenezer Baptist
Church, who knew Carter.
We had a big rally in
Piedmont Park in Atlanta.
Daddy King put his arms around
him, embraced him and said,
"Jimmy, we know you're
a good man.
We know what you mean
and we support you."
And that was over.
And then the other, of course,
in the general election,
was a Playboy interview.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Now, who
advised him to give an interview
to Playboy and what
did he say to Playboy
that got him in trouble?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
First of all,
there were not very
many volunteers
who will say they're the ones
who recommended it [laughter].
This is one case
where it was not me.
It was Jody Powell, his Press
Secretary and Gerry Rafshoon,
his Communications Director.
And why? It was because they had
the sense, as we were broadening
to go country-wide,
that he was seen
as an uptight Baptist Southern.
And they had to show
that he was a real guy.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Okay.
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
So what better place
to do that than Playboy?
Now actually, the
interview was very anodyne.
Basic policy questions, the
kind you and I worked on dozens
of policy papers for him on.
The problem was as the reporter
was leaving his house in Plains,
Carter thought his
tape recorder was off.
And so, as he's going
out the door, he said,
"By the way, you're a Baptist.
What is the Baptist
view of sex?"
And thinking the tape recorder
is off, he said, "Well,
you know, Jesus said that
of course, a man and a woman
in marriage should not have
sex outside of marriage.
But man are honest, they will
have lust in their heart."
There it was, headline,
Playboy interview
with a provocative
model on the front,
"Carter, Lust in Your Heart."
Well here, the whole image
that had been built up
and a realistic image of
a happily married man,
a real religious
man, was busted.
And that all really
was a very big setback.
>> David M. Rubinstein: But he
overcame that and ultimately,
he moves forward
to the nomination.
So he gets the nomination
in New York City
but before the nomination
can be given,
he has to pick a vice-president.
Why did he pick Mondale?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
So he picked Mondale
for several reasons.
First, there was a very thorough
interviewing process done
by his lawyer, Charlie
Kirbo in Atlanta.
And Mondale won for
several reasons.
The first is he did
his homework.
He read Carter's book,
Why Not the Best .
He read everything about him.
The chemistry was
there, both with Joan,
his wife, and Rosalynn.
He needed a Northern liberal.
He needed someone
experienced in the Senate.
He needed someone who was strong
with the constituency
groups he was weak with --
Jews, organized labor
and liberals.
But there's a humorous
part to this too.
There were several other
candidates who vied for the job.
And one made the mistake of
saying, "By the way, Jimmy.
You should know --
thinking this would help --
one of my distant relatives
was General Sherman."
[Laughter] Well, the march
through Georgia is still
remembered to this day.
That did not help.
The other one said, "You know,
I want you to know that one
of my favorite foods
is blue-eyed peas."
[ Laughter ]
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right.
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
So [laughter],
Mondale did not say
"blue-eyed peas."
>> David M. Rubinstein:
So Mondale is selected
and then the general election
campaign against the incumbent
but never again elected
President Gerald Ford.
There were presidential debates.
Now there had never been
presidential debates before
except in John Kennedy's --
>> Stuart Eizenstat: In 1960.
>> David M. Rubinstein: -- 1960
but why did Carter agree to it?
Who challenged who
for the debates
and how did you prepare
Carter for the debates?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
So we challenged Ford
because we thought it
was important to go
on to a national stage
and demonstrate we could
go toe-to-toe with him.
And you and I helped prepare
briefing books for him.
And I have to say again,
in one of my mistakes,
I prepared a briefing book
and I'm not exaggerating,
that was six inches thick.
I mean, that's not how you
brief a president for a debate.
You give him questions
and answers and repose.
He refused also, out
of hubris, to practice.
Absolutely no practice.
The first question
and the first debate
in Philadelphia was a softball.
We had run against
the "Ford recession"
against unemployment
and high inflation.
The first question so
predictable is, "Mr. Carter,
what would you do
for the economy?"
He totally blew the answer.
I mean, I almost
fell off my chair.
What saved us was
the second debate.
In the second debate which
was the foreign policy debate,
Ford was asked the following
question, "What do you think
about the Soviet domination
of Eastern Europe?"
We're in the Cold War.
And Ford says, "There
is no Soviet domination
of the Soviet Union."
And Max Frankel from the
New York Times says, "Now,
did I hear you correctly?
Are you saying the Soviet
Union doesn't dominate
Eastern Europe?"
"Yes, that's what I mean."
What he meant didn't
dominate the Soviet people.
Carter just latched
onto it and he said,
"I think the Czech Americans
and the Polish Americans
and the Ukrainian Americans
would very much disagree."
Of course, they do.
And Ford didn't realize and
I interviewed Jim Baker,
one of the 350 people
who was interviewed,
who was his campaign manager.
And he said for three days,
they tried to convince Ford he
had made an egregious mistake.
He needed to apologize
and he didn't.
That really turned the
tables and it showed
that this one term Georgia
governor could handle the job
as well as a 25-year
congressman in the White House.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
So Carter gets elected
and when he's elected, he says,
"Okay, I had a secret group
that was preparing
for my election,
a pre-election transition group.
I'm now going to have
them run the transition
and presumably the government."
And then there were the people
working at the campaign.
So what happened
in the transition
between the two groups clashing
about who was really going
to run the transition?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: Well,
this was a forerunner
of the organizational
problems that I like to talk
about in the White House
because unbeknownst to us,
Carter had asked Jack Watson,
a very, very talented attorney
and Charlie Kirbo's partner,
to have a separate
transition group working
on the same policies you and I
were working on in the trenches.
But when you work 24 hours
a day, seven days a week
and your candidate wins, you
expect to have a major job.
Well, so did the people in
this other transition group.
And there was a tremendous
clash between them
that was resolved only
in the last few days
before we took over.
So it caused a real problem.
But on a more positive
note during the transition,
Mondale reluctantly decided
to run for vice-president
because his mentor,
Hubert Humphrey had been
humiliated by Lyndon Johnson.
Humiliated -- not
allowed in the meetings.
He often waited half-an-hour,
the Vice President
of the United States
in front of the staff
of like Joe [Inaudible]
for a meeting.
He was not given access
to secret documents.
He wanted to make sure
that didn't happen.
So he sent Carter and
the transition a memo
with 10 requests, access to all
papers, access to all meetings,
one-on-one lunches
in the White House.
And Carter approved
every one of them
and added one additional one.
And that is, anyone who knows
anything about real estate,
its location, location,
location.
It's the same in politics.
He moved the Vice President's
Office to where it is today,
right down the hall
in the West Wing
and that location
said everything
about Mondale's stature.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Now,
Carter didn't really know most
of the people he selected
to be cabinet officers.
How did he actually
select the cabinet?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: The
cabinet was selected in part
by Ham Jordan, who was his
de facto chief of staff,
by Kirbo and by Mondale.
And Mondale got a lot of
the people he had known,
Bob Birkeland, Adams and
others into the position.
Now, the key two positions and
here was my first disagreement
as he was coming into office.
So I was the only campaign
aide who Carter allowed to sit
in on the post-election
CIA briefings in Plains.
He was now president-elect.
And during one of the
breaks in the briefings,
we went off to the
side of his house.
He said, "Stu, I'm thinking of
appointing Cy Vance as Secretary
of State and Zbig Brzezinski as
my National Security Advisor."
And of course, because I
had coordinated all policy,
I worked on foreign policy.
We had a foreign policy group.
I said, "Mr. President,
either one would be great
for that position but
together, they would be poison.
It won't work."
And he said, "Why?"
And I said, "Because
Cy is a dove
on the Soviet Union
and Zbig is a hawk.
And you will have great
difficulty reconciling it."
And he said, "I like
differences of opinion.
I can handle it."
The fact is it created a
dissonance on foreign policy
that was not resolved until the
Soviets invaded Afghanistan,
Christmas 1979 when
Carter clearly landed
into the hardline
camp of Brzezinski.
>> David M. Rubinstein: So
Carter was criticized early
on for having a bunch
of Georgians
who were inexperienced.
You had worked in
the White House
but you were still
only 34 years old.
The others were actually
younger than you.
Do you think Carter
made a mistake at having
so many Georgians who had
no experience around him?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: It's
actually 33 but that's okay.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Thirty-three [laughter]?
Okay.
>> Stuart Eizenstat: But yes,
the answer is every president
brings his campaign staff
with him.
It's the Boston mafia
with Kennedy.
It's the Austin mafia
with LBJ and so forth.
But the difference is those
were people who knew Washington,
who had themselves
been in the Congress
or in central positions.
So Carter came in without
one day's experience,
have never been in the
White House, brought people
into the White House as his
top aides who had never been
in the White House, and then
made the fatal error thinking
that the real problem with
Watergate was Bob Haldeman,
Nixon's chief of staff
who kept everyone away.
And that was not the problem.
The problem was Haldeman
was a crook [laughter].
The chief of staff is essential
and Ford, also, after the pardon
of Nixon, when he
became president,
he had been a congressman.
He didn't want a
chief of staff either.
The first weeks of the Ford
presidency were chaotic
and Dick Cheney told me
in one of the interviews,
he became his chief of staff
that they gave Cheney a broken
bicycle wheel when he was going
out as staff to show that
the system that Ford had
and that Carter ended
up adopting
which is called the
spokes, the wheel where five
or six presidential
aides have equal access
and there's no chief
of staff was wrong.
And he left that broken bicycle
wheel on [Inaudible] offices
and said, "It's a mistake.
Don't do it."
But Carter didn't listen.
And he didn't have
a chief of staff
and he didn't have an
experienced chief of staff.
Reagan learned the lesson.
What did Reagan do when he won?
He also was inexperienced
in Washington.
He had Jim Baker, who had
been the campaign manager
of his opponent, George H.W.
Bush as his chief of staff.
That made all the
difference in the world.
>> David M. Rubinstein: So
Carter is elected president
of the United States, the
first Democratic president
in eight years.
The Congress are
controlled by the Democrats
so the Democrats just do
whatever Carter wants.
Is that right or it didn't
happen that way [laughter]?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
Maybe if it was Republican
but this is a Democrat.
>> David M. Rubinstein: So why
didn't they like him better?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
First of all, they did.
One of the things and the
myths that I try to puncture is
that he was unsuccessful
with Congress.
Congress passed almost 70%
of his legislation according
to two independent surveys,
just under the percent
of the legendary Lyndon Johnson.
The problem was, however,
that he proposed, David,
so much at the same time,
so many major priorities --
welfare reform, tax reform,
health insurance and so forth,
Panama Canal, Seoul Treaty --
that it got lost and he had
not the capacity of showing
that half-a-loaf was a victory.
He was so moralistic that
compromising became difficult.
So we achieved an enormous
amount but it always paled
in comparison to
what we had proposed.
And the Democratic Party was
very much split between --
he had two bases,
Southern conservatives
and the Northern liberals.
And in the Senate, in
particular, Tip in the House,
Tip O'Neill -- they
passed everything.
The Senate became an Indian
burial ground for a lot
of his legislation
because of this division.
In the end again, we achieved a
lot but it was done with a lot
of blood on the table.
>> David M. Rubinstein: How
about Carter's working style?
Did he like to be
briefed orally?
They liked to read memos?
Did he like to call the
staff in and ask questions?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So
David, you have been a CEO,
just stepped down, and you
interview CEOs for your program.
The president of the United
States is the chief executive
officer of the largest
enterprise in the world.
Trillions of dollars of
revenue, of expenditures,
tens of millions of employees.
But the president
constitutionally has very
few powers.
He's the commander-in-chief
and that's it.
Carter failed to recognize
it was his weakness
but also his strength
for reasons I'll
mention in a minute.
He failed to realize
that the president has
to be politician-in-chief.
He has to take the relatively
weak constitutional powers,
unite his party, coax people
to support him, schmooze,
do the small favors, notes
on birthdays, a project here
and there to get a vote.
He had great difficulty
doing that.
He saw the job as more
of an academic job.
He made decisions
by written memoranda
and he read voraciously.
He always wanted more and
more and more information.
He would sometimes circle our
decision memos with misspellings
and grammatical errors.
Now mind you, that's a lot
better way to make decisions
than what we see in tweets
but still [laughter],
it was -- it was a problem.
And the human contact on
decisions is important.
It empowers cabinet officers.
It empowers the Congress.
When they see the president,
when he can see the
pressures personally --
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right.
So the best way to
convince Carter was to say,
"This would help
you politically."
>> Stuart Eizenstat: Ham
Jordan told me very early on,
he had been Carter's
principal supporter and aide
and the genius behind
the '76 campaign.
He said, "Stu, I want to
give you an early lesson
in the White House.
Never say, Mr. President,
this decision will help you
politically or you'll lose."
He had a very odd
view of politics.
He was a ferocious
campaigner but he wanted
to do what he considered
the right thing politically
and then hope that the political
chips ultimately would fall
his way.
Again, failing to recognize
you have to marry politics
and policy all the time.
So again, we never
said, "Mr. President,
this decision will
help you politically."
Now that was his weakness
but it was his strength.
Because of that, he
was willing to take
on issues others wouldn't
-- the Panama Canal Treaty,
the Middle East peace
process, the energy policy --
knowing it would
hurt him politically,
knowing it would be bloody.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Did he approve people
using the tennis courts?
That was a rumor always.
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
Well, I mean,
this is -- this is such a myth.
The fact is, he was incredibly
generous to us as a staff.
He did things that no
other president did.
He allowed his senior staff
to have Camp David which,
by the way, he almost sold along
with the presidential Sequoia
as a way of saving money.
But he let us use that on
weekends which was a godsend.
And he let his staff
use the tennis court.
He only said, "Sign
up so I'm not on
or Rosalynn's not on
at the same time."
The notion that he micromanaged
the schedule is just incorrect
but it fit in with this notion
of excessive attention to detail
that was actually an act of
huge generosity to his staff.
>> David M. Rubinstein:
So let's talk
about what some people would
say was his greatest success,
Camp David.
He tried to get in the middle of
the Middle East peace process.
He invited Sadat and
Begin to Camp David.
Was that an idea that
everybody thought was good
and how did he actually
pull that off
over a 13-day period of time?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So Anwar
Sadat, the president of Egypt,
made a historic trip to
Jerusalem to start the process.
Then an impasse developed.
They simply couldn't resolve
their major differences.
He wanted everything
back from the Sinai.
So Carter, in an
act of desperation,
thinking that Sadat's whole
historic effort would fail,
took a risk that almost all
of his advisers advised
him not to do.
He invited them
to the presidential
retreat at Camp David.
Through 13 agonizing
days and nights,
Carter personally
wrote 20 drafts.
He negotiated separately
with Menachem Begin,
the prime minister of Israel
and with Sadat because they were
like two scorpions
in the bottle.
They never met except the
first day and the last.
And then he added
two personal touches.
And compare that with some of
the summits we've seen recently.
Number one, the first of
the Sundays of the 13 days,
he took them to Gettysburg, to
the battlefield to demonstrate
that five wars were enough.
Sadat was a general.
He knew Pickett's charge.
And Begin was so moved,
he actually verbatim did
the Gettysburg Address.
And then the last Sunday, we
were very close to an agreement
but not there, the 13th day.
And Begin said, "Mr.
President, I've had it.
No more compromises.
I've got an El Al
plane waiting for me.
Get me out of here."
He called it a luscious
concentration camp.
Carter knowing that this
would blow up the Middle East
and his own presidency,
knowing what Begin loved
which was his grandchildren,
he got eight photographs
of himself, Sadat and
Begin at Camp David,
personally autographed them,
walked them over to Begin's
cabin, handed it to them.
And saw tears well
up in Begin's eyes
as he read each of his names.
He put his bags down and said,
"I'll make one last try,"
and the rest is history.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right,
so they got the agreement.
They came down with it to
the White House [applause].
But then it still took time
for Carter had to go back
to the Middle East and
do some of the summit --
>> Stuart Eizenstat: Yes
and this was even more.
Everybody thinks the end
of it was Camp David.
Camp David was a framework.
It wasn't a binding treaty.
There was supposed to be
three months to finish it.
In six months, they
still hadn't.
So Carter took another risk.
And this was unanimously
opposed.
He went back to the
region to try
to put this back
into a formal treaty.
And again, it looked
like we had failed.
The last day, Carter was
in the King David Hotel.
He was -- already
got his bags packed.
The air space was
cleared for Air Force One.
Begin calls and says,
"Mr. President,
I'd like to come see
you for breakfast."
Carter not expecting it,
says to us in the lobby,
"Would you please entertain
the Prime Minister while I get
dressed and ready?"
So Begin says to us, "You know,
this is a very famous
hotel, the King David."
I said, "Yes, I understand."
He said, "No, not for
the reasons you think.
When I was head of the Irgun
during the British occupation,
I blew this hotel up [laughter].
Don't worry.
I'm not going to do it while
the President is here."
But that breakfast
ended up sealing it.
And then we had a treaty
that has not been violated
in any iota for 40 years
central to Israel security.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Okay.
>> Stuart Eizenstat: And the --
>> David M. Rubinstein:
For 40 years,
the treaty has not
been violated.
There's peace between
Egypt and Israel.
And why is it that
Carter is not that popular
in the Jewish community?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: All right,
so this is very painful for me
as a member of the
Jewish community.
Here's a president that
gave Israel its first peace
with its most powerful Arab
enemy, Egypt, who broke the back
of the Arab boycott with the
Arab boycott legislation,
who was the unquestioned father
of the U.S. Holocaust Memorial
Museum, who championed the cause
of Soviet Jewry and got
a doubling of immigration
and saved Natan Sharansky's
life during his trial.
And who saved 50,000
Iranian Jews during the
Ayatollah's reign.
And yet, he gets the lowest
percentage of Jewish votes
of any Democratic candidate.
Why? First because to achieve
that peace in the Middle East,
there was a lot of glass
that had to be broken,
a lot of pressure
was put on Israel.
Second, he had very
difficult relations with Rabin
and particularly with Begin.
Begin was the first Likud
prime minister after 30 years
of Labor prime ministers who
believed that Israel had a claim
to everything between the
Mediterranean and the Jordan.
And this was very
difficult for him to accept.
And so there were
repeated clashes
and most important perhaps,
he analogized the plight
of the Palestinians to the
plight of the African-Americans
with whom he grew up in a county
that was two-thirds black,
where he played with them but
couldn't go to school with them.
And he said to me
in my interview,
"The white police
treated blacks better
than the IDF treated
the Palestinians."
Now, I've argued with him
about the [inaudible].
That was his belief.
He saw it through
civil rights lenses
and then the final coup
came 30 years after he left
with his book, Apartheid
or Peace and
that really sealed the verdict.
>> David M. Rubinstein: So
let's switch for a moment
to the Iranian's hostage crisis.
The Shah leaves Iran,
forced out.
Carter ultimately lets him
in to the United States.
Why did he let him do that and
why did Carter not do anything
for one year in terms
of the hostages
and leaving the White House
or why did he make the hostage
crisis such a big thing?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: So I don't
think it's fair to blame Carter
for the Iranian revolution
any more than it would be fair
to blame Eisenhower for
the Castro revolution
or Obama for Mubarak falling.
But we made huge mistakes.
The first was letting the
Shah in for medical treatment.
Now this is the worst failure
in intelligence history.
The CIA did not know that the
principal ally we had put back
on the throne in 1953 had lost
his political support at home
and was getting cancer
treatments for five years.
So he wants to come in
for cancer treatments.
Carter is the last holdout.
He said to us point blank,
"I think if we let him in,
the radicals will try to
capture our hostages."
And everybody said including
Rockefeller, David Rockefeller
and Kissinger outside who
were organizing the effort,
"You can't let an ally
of 30 years down."
So he let him in and the
hostages [inaudible].
Then the mistake was we --
I recommended and Brzezinski
recommended immediate military
action, not bombing but
manning the harbors,
keeping the oil from coming out.
He refused.
He said to the hostages'
families,
"My first priority is
getting your loved ones
out safe and sound."
He did but at great
political cost.
He holed himself up in the White
House and that really showed
that he was a prisoner, a
hostage himself and then
of course, the failed rescue
effort doomed the presidency.
And it was not due to
too few helicopters.
He ordered two more than
was ordered by the military.
It was because four
military services, David,
had never practiced the
whole exercise together.
>> David M. Rubinstein: Right,
so despite all these problems,
Carter was the nominee
of his party.
He had a contest against
Ted Kennedy in 1980.
Do you think had
Kennedy not run,
Carter might have been
a stronger candidate
in the general elections?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
There's no question about it.
I mean, Ford, in
part lost in '76
because Reagan challenged him.
It split the party and it was
over national health insurance
which just was not
affordable at this time.
Kennedy never reconciled
after the convention.
There was no holding of hands.
He didn't campaign
with him actively.
That would have made
a huge difference.
At the end, however,
it was inflation
and the hostage crisis
that did [inaudible].
>> David M. Rubinstein: So
I remember thinking then,
I was 31 years old
and we wanted to run
against Ronald Reagan
because he was 69.
I thought, "How can
anybody 69 possibly be able
to do anything?"
I'm now 69 so it doesn't
look as bad as it did then
but [laughter] why did we want
to run against Ronald Reagan?
>> Stuart Eizenstat: We wanted
to run against Ronald Reagan
but we thought that he was
a trigger-happy cowboy,
a grade B movie star
from California.
And Jess Unruh, who we
called in, he was the head
of the California
Democratic Party said,
"You're underestimating
this guy.
He's a great politician."
We didn't realize
how great he was.
Now what happened was we got
at Fox in terms of the debate.
We agreed with only eight
days left to debate him.
And that debate was failed
because it took away
the fear factor.
Because we had inflation,
because we had, you know,
the Iran crisis, all the
good things we had done had
gone obscured.
So we ran a very negative
campaign against him.
And he was very loquacious,
very you know,
sincere, very articulate.
It took away the fear factor
and our polls went down.
But here's the interesting
thing which nobody recognizes
in this landslide loss.
The last weekend before
the Tuesday election,
by all independent polls,
we were even or ahead.
So the halo effect
that Reagan got
from the debate had evaporated.
And then here's where
Iran comes in again.
We're in Chicago, 3:00 o'clock
in the morning, at the Hilton.
The White House calls and
says, "Be ready in 45 minutes.
The President's going
back to the White House.
There's a new offer
from the Iranians."
And I begged him not to go.
I said, "Look, you
can look at it here.
It's not going to
be satisfactory."
And it wasn't.
He went back.
It brought the whole thing
back, the whole Iranian thing
and his polls collapsed.
And all the good things
-- energy security,
the greatest environmental
president ever,
all the ethics laws
which were there,
the modern vice [inaudible]
going to China, normalization,
human rights and
foreign policy --
all of these things
were forgotten
because of the hostage crisis.
>> David M. Rubinstein: How is
Jimmy Carter's health today?
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
Jimmy Carter's health
today is remarkable.
He's 94 in October, October 1st.
He announced three years ago
that he had metastatic melanoma.
We thought it was the end.
I went down to see him.
It was a day or two
before he got immunotherapy
which is a new precision
medicine
that it's not like chemotherapy.
It activates the immune system.
Three years later, knock on
wood, he's as good as ever.
He travels.
He's articulate.
He's been given a
new lease on life
and it's really a wonderful way
of [inaudible] blessing
[applause].
>> David M. Rubinstein:
Well, my --
we haven't had time for
questions from the audience
because we ran out of time.
But I hope you all think this
was an interesting story.
I highly recommend this book
by Stuart Eizenstat
on President Carter.
Thank you very much, Stuart.
>> Stuart Eizenstat:
Thank you, David.
[ Applause ]